[Musique]
on va vous montrer à quel point la glace
l'eau peut faire des ravages
parce que là on est à l'entrée et voyez
toute cette glace donc y est entré d'un
coup sec à l'intérieur finalement de ce
bar salon de quilles salle de billard
qui est assez immense là on entre en ce
moment dans l'établissement et on va
voir vous karine parce que c'est vous la
propriétaire qu'est ce qu'on voit les
ici c'est arrivé soudainement ce qu'on
voit ici en fait c'est un désastre total
on essayait de d'installer les pompes
concours et moins mon conjoint qui est
aussi copropriétaire avec moi à l'époque
de terrasson complètement défoncée par
la glace l'on traverse présentement ok
le courant était intense avec des glaces
je me faisais fricassée de tous bords
tous côtés
le comptoir ici du barreau monte plus
haut que les lumières le canton riche
homme s'est soulevée par la force de
l'eau y flottait hier finit par
redescendre
c'est sûrement dans votre salle de chi
chi chi le prolongement du bas
finalement oui et laïciste et pleins
d'eau partout là ici c'est plein d'eau
comme on peut voir en dessous il doit
avoir trois à quatre pieds d'eau en
dessous des allées dalphond on voit dans
les fenêtres la trace d'eau le plancher
au complet était flou telle était plus
haut plus haut que loulou physiquement
et mentalement comment ça va je démolis
je suis démoli gepeep d'emploi mon
conjoint non plus
en tout ce qu'on investisse et si mes
employés ont pu travailler parce que
vous avez été blessé par ces glaces auto
oui mais oui le jeu veut prendre rendez
vous avec le médecin et quand j'avais
une minute
merci beaucoup merci pour votre aide à
rien